[Music]
whenever the fbi hears a piece of gossip
or information such as i saw someone so
out with another woman not his wife
we're supposed to write everything down
in memos
all your secrets
are safe
with us
how long have you been in the fbi 30
years that's a lot of information
i give you the guardian of the american
dream
mark phelps fidelity integrity bravery
ladies and gentlemen the g-man's g-man
[Music]
what is it you better get down here
[Music]
five men were caught early this morning
in the washington headquarters of the
democratic national committee
here's what we know the men who broke
into the watergate are not the end of
this thing but the beginning
no more interviews with white house
people without permission what we put
the investigation to bed in two days the
director of the fbi ordered the fbi to
stop its own investigation
tonight is in the midst of what may be
the most critical constitutional crisis
in its history
the white house has no authority over
the fbi
we can at all
all this truth
i must be terrified of you
no one can stop the driving force of an
fbi investigation
not even the fbi
what you're doing will bring down the
whole house of cards washington post
this comes from classified fbi files the
white house has it and now you have it
fbi agents have established watergate
incident as political sabotage
there's a spy in the fbi the white house
is going to sanitize the entire town
how high
how high does this go what about the
president is the president lying
they're all lying
there's a nickname for you at the paper
deep throat
[Music]
you